I know that it's been an abusive
relationship and I'm the only one that
can change that before anything worse
happens to myself in front of my kids so
I called and luckily they had a space
after a 10-year abusive relationship it
was the intensity of lockdown that
finally triggered Caroline to escape
with her two children that was the final
straw for me it's little things like
picking up on my appearance just being
stuck in the house with somebody that
just has outbursts and rage I just
didn't feel safe being there I suppose
it's all right when he works Monday to
Friday he's out of the house really all
week but having your children scared of
their own dad it's just a big wake-up
call
national figures suggest lockdown has
created a pressure cooker behind closed
doors the number of arrests have surged
calls to one national abuse helpline
rose 49 percent we've come to a refuge
in Swindon where referrals are up 80
percent in one week we normally get
about two referrals a week and we are
just inundated at the moment and having
to prioritize risk which is really
tricky when you get someone in that that
you know that needs refuge but actually
that's matched against somebody that
really needs refuge so you happen to
prioritize when actually everybody needs
it and the jobs harder outreach workers
would normally meet potential clients in
cafes now that can't happen you don't
get those moments so for pre-weighed you
can go out and do your you know do your
shopping or go to work and it is just
having somebody there over your shoulder
24 hours a day and the control that that
person has has just increased tenfold
domestic abuse is one of the most
prevalent crimes in our society the
domestic abuse bill debate in the
Commons couldn't be more timely as MPs
consider how to get more financial
support for those fleeing abuse the
national statistics normally are one in
three women will suffer domestic abuse
within their lifetime and two women are
killed every week by the current or
former partner so it's there it's always
there it's
killer effectively and this really helps
bring domestic abuse into the main focus
the hardest thing is finding the
strength to leave but that can be made
easier if people know that the support
is there there are women out there who
might be watching this thinking I've got
to get out but I don't know how to I
don't know how to find the strength I
don't know what to do what would you
advise be this is why I really would it
to come down and do this because there
is a way out and isn't it's not always a
bad one you have that strength within
you and do it for your kids if you can't
do it for yourself
Jason Farrell Sky News